thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a revealing
wild ride with Stevo man
I've been talking about it for a long
long time me and my girl we're gonna
open up an animal sanctuary man we're
gonna buy a big property it's gonna be
great and ladies and gentlemen we are
finally doing it where on how much land
like what the the wedding
uh-huh find it all out and a whole lot
more of incredibly revealing and radical
news here on the Wild Ride podcast now
good little grind in on my new ramp and
let's get into it
how old is Mark Zuckerberg
I think he's my age
let's guess
because if she's anywhere near my age I
am jealous
[Laughter]
39.9 you think you think you can how old
is Elon Musk 47 46. no 49.
how old was Zuckerberg when he said yeah
why are they even talking about Elon
Musk
almost two years old okay I think yeah I
don't want to swear we're that close to
the top so here we go we're gonna we're
gonna start up
right here
ladies and gentlemen me and Scott
Randolph Paul Briskey skinny Vinny yeah
dudes with Isaac Manning the computer
for relevant information that's right
just let us know that Mark Zuckerberg is
39 years old and Elon Musk is 52. but
you just said you asked his age and
you're like if he's anywhere near my age
I want to call him out do you think you
got that do I think I have Mark
Zuckerberg yeah hasn't even training
like isn't he he's like a super ripped
yeah he's super rich black belt Jiu
Jitsu yeah okay check this out places
like a psycho genius he'll be like
calculating everything you know check
this out dude TMZ today says that now
Elon Musk is not being taken seriously
like it's off it's out and now they're
trying to pair up
Mark Zuckerberg with an actual
fighter from the UFC roster wow like
Mark Zuckerberg is just gonna fight
somebody in the UFC oh he'll get worse
yeah
who do you give him to you know like uh
CM Punk let him back in the UFC like I
mean I don't know dude be a chick okay
I'm not trying to be an [__] just
like uh maybe that evens it out a little
bit a chick would [__] him up
the thing is dude Mark Zuckerberg was uh
like legitimately in a jiu jitsu
competition and one yeah you can't help
but hear that and speculate that like
they gave him like the they let him win
but then again at the same time no the
dude is super ripped he has an octagon
in his backyard he's training his ass
off
like yeah I I mean I don't know if he
can handle UFC roster talent but it's
getting a little bit interesting with
Mark Zuckerberg it looks like he rolled
with Lex Friedman now the reason why I
said I want to challenge my Mark
Zuckerberg and call it matters because I
heard such good things about Bradley
Martin calling everybody out with no
intentions of fighting he's just trying
to get clicks oh he's calling he's
moving people out yeah he's street
fights like it's already just being big
helper yeah you should fight Amanda
Nunes I mean I don't want to fight
anybody dude I don't want to fight
anybody dude maybe Elon Musk though you
could take I mean I guess
Elon Musk is huge he's like six 230
pounds is he 6'4 like Mark Zuckerberg is
like 145 and Elon Musk is like 2 30.
okay now but let's just say Zuckerberg
and
and Elon Musk did fight who do you have
I mean Zuckerberg yeah for sure
I but just the size I could think that
the odds are very very close in
Zuckerberg versus Elon Musk because I
really think so is 230 pounds what's
Zuckerberg yeah but like dude if they
get to the floor he's done with the
jujitsu guy and I feel like Zuckerberg
when Israel out of Sania fought
was able to
much bigger okay that's true
like no matter how good you are at Jiu
Jitsu I think when a guy is that much
bigger and that much heavier than yeah
but do you think do you think uh musk
has any sort of like background or has a
background in kickboxing now that
doesn't help him in the grappling
department but he does
he does yeah now we don't want to
alienate everybody with our high level
Combat Sports knowledge for sure
right I mean let's let's give everybody
some uh some some fun stuff to start off
with here we are we have no big guest in
the podcast we're thrilled that we've
had some success with uh without having
to get a guess you know how much it
stresses me out you need a huge
celebrity every week to be able to do
this without a guest and have people
enjoy it it's awesome yeah you were
really stressed out I mean [__] it we
were all stressed out about the numbers
and the podcast growing and we finally
tested out the no podcast or the new
guests you were you were super terrified
I was like oh my god it worked yeah and
the people loved it like I see more
comments in the section saying do more
do more do more love this more than the
guests
Paul briskey's big news
the gorgeous Paul Briskey oh this is
rough news for the ladies I got married
y'all wow oh I didn't even see the ring
yet oh yeah I got a little ring on
[__] stoked man yeah I got married
sick I remember asking you in the
airport if you were gonna get a ring and
you're like nah no did I say that no
yeah I was planning to get a ring for
something you'd say yeah
this whole institution thing about
marriage no we were talking about
because my wife didn't take my last name
which you guys were like oh that would
be a deal breaker for me and that was
the conversation on the honeymoon did
your wife have dinner with another man
we had a really we had a really awesome
time we had awesome dinner it's killer
man I'm so stoked to be married and you
went to the courthouse yeah we did at
the courthouse it was just the two of us
it was epic and like yeah I wouldn't do
it any other way was it the best sex
you've ever had in your life that night
it was a wonderful time and I
had like more special though like oh
yeah everything was like they say
marriage like or I've always felt like
what's the point like there's no
difference if we want to break up we'll
still break up like if we wake up and
hate each other one day like what is the
difference but it does feel a little
different like I look at her a little
differently now do you feel different
yeah I guess I kind of do I feel a
little more like adult honestly wow
that's sick yeah are you still trying to
move to Arizona
I don't know I don't know if I'm gonna
move or not like we play the Zillow game
a lot we're always looking at houses
here houses there
I mean I know you know about that Zillow
game yeah Zillow game is fun but um but
I have no idea I'm sorry no go ahead go
ahead I just did it that's your show I
know but dude I'm really really
important to me to be respectful of the
listeners and and uh when I do that I
want to really take it seriously yeah
but they want to hear more from you than
from me so
um are we putting this episode out
before or after Mark Normand I I feel
like it makes more sense before before
then this will be my big announcement
the the animal sanctuary that lux and I
have been talking about
uh starting up how we're waiting to get
married ourselves on the property that
we're gonna buy for the animal sanctuary
we're doing it we found the property
we're buying it offers been accepted
inspections are done now we just had a
big scare about like we can't get it
insured because the somehow they you
can't
buy a house without first insuring it
and then they're like Stevo we're gonna
turn that guy really really I don't even
know why they know it's Stevo but
um but but I don't know like if we had
this morning we woke up with a real
terror attack that we can't buy at the
property but um I do believe we uh are
actually going to be able to it was a
false alarm and the property is in
Tennessee
reasonably close to Nashville
and God it's so dope man it really is
sick yeah but now I'm having like a
panic attack
that uh just how just to set up I mean
like it occurred to me okay like our
cars
we're not going to drive all the way to
Nashville to go to the house you should
get a pickup dude I can see in the
pickup out there like a 1980s Chevy
pickup
stick [__] I mean I think you need a
pickup like yeah you're a [__] farmer
now bro like with that much land you're
gonna have a lot of [__] to do like
you're gonna need them dude we're gonna
literally a lot of [__] like we're gonna
have goats chickens you gotta get
overalls you got to get like that you
gotta get some steel toes like Paul
brisk is married I'm getting married
soon too we're finally doing it yeah
we're starting to try and and
where are you guys yeah
we're not sure about y'all
now whether you're getting married or
not
be disgusting your bed cannot be
disgusting that's why you need miracle
made these are bed sheets that are
infused with silver which makes them
temperature controlled never too cold
never too hot plus this science which
was inspired by NASA is responsible for
making sure that these sheets do not
collect bacteria
like 99.9 of bacteria doesn't stand a
chance so your sheets are not gross now
get a load of this
the listeners of the Wild Ride podcast
if you go to try
miracle.com Stevo you get a free
three-piece towel set plus more than 40
percent off your order my God and on top
of that it's a 30-day risk-free money
back guarantee ladies and gentlemen this
might be the best one of all go to try
miracle.com
Stevo now let's get back to it so what
does that mean like are you gonna stay
there most of the time like what do you
plan on going down with like I don't
mind being completely candid about the
fact that I'm considering
spending the required minimum of six
months and one day in Tennessee to
qualify as a Tennessee State resident
and not pay state income tax same reason
Joe Rogan moved to Texas they don't have
state income tax Tennessee is this is
exactly that way no state income tax
so then that means like and by the way
if you're on tour it doesn't count like
if you're not physically in Tennessee
for that six months and one days then
you're out of luck so being on tour
doesn't count so I would have to take
like my schedule and really really
meticulously say okay
I can spend four months of the year on
tour
then
less than two months of the year in LA
and a full six months and one day
minimum in Tennessee and then I
qualified and this is every year right
I've been any year that I want to
qualify for a Tennessee state residency
for sure but what if you what if
Tennessee was your only residency your
only residence and you were someone who
toured more than six months out of the
year does that person
state tax somewhere like how does that
work that's uh like what's Rogan having
to do if he if he were to be touring
over six months that that becomes more
of a uh tax attorney question okay you
know like being that I'm a California
state resident like otherwise you know
like I would say they would just default
me back to California yeah you know at
least yeah yeah okay it's because you're
gonna have two residences right and I
don't know and I don't want to bore the
listeners with this either it's just
pretty interesting it's huge lifestyle
huge life decision
yeah and and um
if I'm honest I don't know that I want
to spend that much time in Tennessee
right now like what I want is to just
start setting up that property I want
I'm dying to get uh you know registered
like uh animal sanctuary organization as
a full-on like legitimate charity and
non-profit which is legally known as
501c3
that way like we can start building like
you know build building it like
attractions pens you know like I'm kind
of the radical Ranch is what it's called
that's it now as far as the animal
sanctuary goes is it going to be one
specific animal is it going to be a lot
of different animals there are as I
understand it 43 species of farm animals
which are ideal for interaction with
people okay I don't have any interest in
exotic like no elephants Lex and I don't
want any elephants tigers and nothing
exotic or weird yeah what we want is
farm animals that need rescuing and can
interact with people and we want it to
be an attraction
I mean I'm really leaning towards it
being an attraction so you want people
like a line of cars coming into your
house every day I mean it's Monday
through Friday it's it could be like the
Kelly Slater's surf range like it's
special invite you have like nice
Caravans for people to stay in that's a
good analogy that's a good analogy but
like it's a big enough property that
like we could talk like you could keep
it separate so no one's actually going
to your house right yeah because I was
gonna say like there's gonna be so many
people that are going to be like oh [__]
the animals
yeah let's sneak away from this like
tour and like go try and find out yeah
yeah Kelly Slater's is 20 acres I mean
that was [__] huge and you've got
more than double double that yeah I've
got I've got over 40. yeah but then also
your address is just very public which
whatever I guess it ends up that way
anyway huh it's kind of unavoidable yeah
I mean it's a non-profit it's public
yeah financials are publicly I mean
we'll see what happens man but um I uh I
know that this is what we want is to
have the animal sanctuary I really want
it to be
um able to sustain itself with like
revenue streams so that because taking
care of all these animals is not cheap
you know like we have to have like bed
and breakfast like Escape Barn you know
like this and that like human hamster
balls orb you know yeah thing like we
gotta have all this stuff that makes
people want to go there and uh you know
want to like bring in Revenue to pay for
it yeah
they want to live there I want to be set
up there I want to have that as the
future my dad is furious with me for uh
pulling the trigger on this really yeah
what did he want he wants me to wait
until the real estate prices come down
and I'm not waiting for that I'm buying
at the top of the market right before
the crash
dumbest thing so so we put on there the
stock market crashed because I thought
it was interesting that Michael burry
just shorted the market 1.6 billion on
when he did the housing market crash he
shorted it like 700 million dollars in
now to the stock market yeah okay so now
he just shorted the S P 500 1.6 billion
I mean I believe we are at really I
sometimes I'm Oliver tree podcast right
like yeah you've said it on many
podcasts yeah yeah like Great Depression
level
gnarliness like on the horizon I don't
know why I don't feel that way
like I think things will dip ebb and
flow always
but I don't I don't really see like with
no knowledge of anything I just don't
really feel that that fear yeah I mean
the thing is I mean this guy's shorting
the market is a pretty good is he a
one-hit wonder
but no he's a smart guy he's done it a
couple times he's done a couple that's
the question so things will definitely
take a dip I think he's gonna make his
money like on what he's trying but does
that mean that people are going to be
like standing in the dust and like in
line for milk or whatever like all that
like super super depression well you can
live off the land you can you have cows
you can milk and fat and absolutely the
motivation as well as the animal
sanctuary is to just have
groceries Burgers on Deck yeah you know
you can have goat cheese and are you
gonna build pro are you gonna do crops
too
for sure have crops dying to grow food
yeah that'd be so sick like solar
dying to have the craziest solar farm
windmills I don't know about windmills
but uh Tennessee's got wind
well there you go that's electricity
right there he's got Sun they have
gnarly winners too right not gnarly
Tennessee's uh doesn't snow there I
don't think I mean they'll get like a
couple inches maybe you know but but the
winners are not crazy and the summers
are not crazy yeah even though the
summers are kind of crazy everywhere
like yeah and it's humid probably too
like not as bad as Florida okay nothing
compared to Florida
yeah but yeah all right so we we covered
the Zillow wait can I say one more thing
about my marriage my wife and I have a
podcast called the Elk Lodge podcast so
go check it out we've done 83 episodes
and we just had Yuka from The Dudesons
on and it was [__] awesome so yeah
check it out yeah I saw a few comments
actually statements saying if Paul had a
podcast I'd listen and I replied and I
sent them and I sent them wow thanks
Vinny yeah dude yeah so yeah now you
guys know I do have my own podcast the
Elk Lodge podcast add a boy anyway how
about we talk about the most epic skate
party we had the other day oh all right
oh do you mean the skate party that
refuses to end because I can't stop
ripping I'll tell you since I got this
ramp I've just gotten more comfortable
learned more tricks and when my lady
watches me skate I'm she's just turned
on to no end and that means I gotta
deliver the D and when I deliver the D I
deliver it real real good baby because I
got my Bluetooth tablets they make
getting in bed with my lady a whole lot
more fun and if you're wondering if they
might make that stuff a lot more fun for
you too I think they will I'm pretty
darn sure of it so go to bluetooth.com
to collect on an entire month's supply
of Bluetooth tablets absolutely for free
all you gotta pay is five bucks for
shipping it couldn't be easier you go to
bluetooth.com you use the promo code
Stevo you consult with the medical
provider right there on the line boom
like that you're signed up you got an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets completely for free all you pay
is five bucks for shipping so one more
time go to bluetooth.com and use the
promo code Stevo and get ready to have a
lot of fun now let's get back to it
it was definitely built a skate ramp in
the backyard yep and it's something
you've been planning for a while I've
been planning it for a while yeah you
know on my Instagram stories I said like
oh since bam personally attacked me now
I'm gonna build a ramp that was so
joking yeah yeah like the the plan to
build my ramp at my house was months
yeah before any of that even happened
and the band beef was just luck
yeah
but yeah the party was sick right like
who all showed up you had I
had a lot more like crazy Heavy Hitters
like uh you know people who uh
expressed interest but like then like
actually couldn't make it there were a
bunch of them but um
dude but the guys who did come did your
call to invite Dalton Dern was the money
call dude every time I I want Dalton to
do everything that involves skating he's
the sickest dick he's the sickest he did
a 540 on my minivan yeah dude early grab
540. it was so gnarly and uh Garrett
Jenner unbelievable at the legend Jeff
Rowley
get out of here we're all like kind of
like like that's Jeff Riley a little
star strip right over there
yeah you said it to me in front of Jeff
Rowley you're like he like did like
that's Jeff Rowley I mean dude I screwed
up and said dude I've gone through
countless pairs of your shoes
I'm like why did I say that yeah I think
we all have Isaac you said like 25 pairs
ever yeah they were so sick like killer
vegan ones too have you guys ever had
ever met before that I don't think so
that was the first time you guys know
the nicest guy in the world so what you
just so Charming cold call them cold DM
he had reached out to me because he owns
uh like a company that makes knives okay
and he does like skateboard
manufacturing like if we need boards
really what kind of and what kind of
knives does he have he has Like a Knife
Company I forget the name of his night
Knife Company but um next time you're
feeling stabby think of that problem I
want a Jeff Raleigh knife yeah
oh like a little word
dude he was so nice though like this is
a small thing but like when he left he's
like he said goodbye personally to every
single person there which is like one of
those little things but like everyone
got to leave being like cool like I
connected which no one felt like oh I
was invisible to Jeff Rowley right like
he was so cool to say goodbye to every
single person yeah and not even like you
know like I'm a big shot kind of way he
just was really kind yeah those are kind
of really nice yeah yeah these are
pretty dope where Jeff Riley's Knife
Company oh I get it it is it yeah
he gave me hatchets too send me a box of
knives and skateboards yeah for people
that don't really skate that much like
myself or at all how how legendary is
Jeff Rowley I mean he was in Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater so like even if you're not a
skateboarder you know Jeff Rowley yeah
that's why I mean let's just say like
when Steve was naming off everybody on
the list like Jamie Thomas P Rod all
that I was just like walking and then he
said Jeff Riley's name I just stopped
really yeah and I looked I was like what
yes
yeah right since we had a fun skate
party all of our trees
like the homies yeah he's like the new
bro
yeah like so we did the podcast with all
our Retreat yeah then he came to the
skate park then he came to my crash test
dummy bit yesterday then he went to
Preston Lacey's dinner party last night
you did yeah yeah yeah he's fully
infiltrated I mean he like he's got to
be traded not infiltrated I don't mean
it in like a red way he's in and yeah
absorbed he's absorbed yeah he's like
LSD in your pocket that just soaks into
your skin I know but they don't even put
it that way dude like no I didn't mean
to you but he's clearly a fan and he's
just like he's in one place that I
didn't expressly invite him to come it's
every time I've invited him he's been
like dude wouldn't miss it for the world
over there he's the best he's cool yeah
he ripped on my ramp Dave England skated
the hell out of my ramp yeah
yeah that was great man
um the Oliver tree like I asked him I
was like how big the venue is on your
tour and he's like you know like 5 000.
he's like but we do like two shows a
night
two shows a night really I mean I don't
know it sounded like he he's adding
shows sometimes so like in one city like
he'll do like 10 000 people wow yeah I
mean he's pretty big yeah like uh and we
were checking his music out we were
jamming in the car we were jamming I
haven't stopped listening to it since we
had him dude it's kind of like really
great it really grew on like electronic
though it's cool
um you mentioned your crash test dummy
thing which we don't have to talk about
too much but you do have a stop I got a
I got a tattoo on my head right now my
head is uh like big shaven like as close
as you can get it
uh I've got this this yamaka tattoo it's
like if it's like literally the crash
test dummy logo
um on top of my head and
um it's it's just yeah and and my neck
is feeling like awfully messed up
because here I've gotten myself in this
situation where I gotta crash all the
time now you know like well the the
first the first crash has has messed up
my neck
um
foreign
if I gotta turn my head I'm like turning
my whole body is it true that Whiplash
gets worse the next day after it happens
um I'm not gonna go that far it's about
the same
yeah but I'm so excited about the ramp I
came home from Whiplash yes
then I went out to Preston Lacey's
birthday dinner and uh came back and
skated again
I was just skating right now oh my god
dude I gotta do the podcast
yeah how was the birthday dinner was it
all of you guys like who was that it was
like the most random little like strip
mall like uh like Armenian chicken joint
like I have no idea what made Prince
want to choose that but we had Wee Man
out
um
uh we man Dave England photography of
retreat Sam macaroni me and a bunch of
us had our ladies dude Oliver tree got
such a kick out of getting to meet Sam
macaroni because he was like such a
Randy rigatoni yeah
he's like dude it's great to meet you he
was so happy to meet you Sam macaroni
yeah it was fun
he totally made up uh what is it Randy
rigatoni yeah he has
and that Oliver tree is really something
a creative guy and you know what else
he's creative about his facial hair man
got that mustache kicking and other than
that totally clean shaven now if you
want to be totally clean shaven then you
better get on over to harrys.com and use
the slash Stevo after that why because
they got the five blade razors best ones
in the world the weighted ergonomic
craft handle plus the the travel case to
protect the blade and the foaming shave
gel all of that put together is the
craft handle kit and it is a 17 value
but it can be yours for just ten dollars
if you go to harrys.com
Stevo this is how I shave it's the only
way I shave and it's what I love Harry's
shaving products so one more time go to
harrys.com
Stevo to get that 17 craft kit for just
10 bucks harrys.com Devo now let's get
back to it they got that that was an
epic day
um yeah I've uh committed myself to
getting into a lot of crashes and I'm
super nervous about it
the next crashes aren't going to be in
um a car
wow they will involve cars sometimes I
know we can't say what we did yesterday
but are you happy with the results
let's see I bought a smart car so they
could crash it into a wall to make sure
the airbags work yeah well dressed up as
a crash test time yeah that to me has
always been just a special wonderful
thing and it's something that I really
wanted to do and um the reality of doing
that is that if if you if you want all
that front end damage and all that like
crazy like that then you're not gonna be
okay
um like I I think that
the airbags worked I got gnarly Whiplash
the footage is great I mean it's funny
it's like like you can't look at that as
like oh my God that's gnarly yeah it's
gnarly but it's more of like wow that's
just plain stupid yeah you bought a car
for no purpose other than to crash it
like uh and and you crash it properly
yeah
like uh the more the more I look at that
that clip that you gave me the more I
love it I totally I love it it's so
funny and the my favorite is like this
is just to deactivate the airbag so that
we can like do the rest of the filming
like let's get these airbags out of the
way thank God the airbags worked so now
we don't have to worry about them for
the rest of the day yeah
that was a really fun day man yeah it
was an expensive day yeah and a fun one
and as I pointed out when I was getting
my crash test dummy tattoo
um you know these bits that I start
putting together of course the this is
the the first bit for my gone too far
tour like these last bucket list shows
I'm gonna be presenting the crash test
dummy footage I'm gonna be like I'm
gonna start uh start working out bits
for the next tour so like that these
final shows of The Bucket List are uh
what do you call it like um kind of
hybrid yeah kind of hybrid you're gonna
get extra uh extra stuff new stuff it's
dope yeah and uh then and the dates
begin September 1st through September
17th okay I've got some editing to do
all right we're going to get that going
um so dude this is this feels fun I this
feels fun I was all stressed out I love
doing these honestly well it's the only
ones I do so maybe that's but like
they're so fun what were you stressed
out about I mean I think just like
everything and like buying the property
in Tennessee well dude it's the biggest
it's like top five biggest decisions of
your life and right you're getting
married that's another one buying a
house which I mean the other ones are
like
shut down touring yeah like uh like
Revenue but you were stoked but you were
stoked like uh 20 minutes before that
and then you came in and you were like I
don't know like uh my manager Adam
called up before and that's all you have
to say
when you bought the property was that
like a one two three go kind of thing or
is that I just knew it like we visited
the property and uh I was just like dude
all right like how many did you visit
before that we did six in one day we
physically wasted six properties in one
day and I was just like none of them
there's none of them this is it like
yeah when you know you know what was it
about this place that you're like oh
that's it
um the way that the the properties all
spread out with like dense Woods that
create different fields like you've got
very distinct different fields
bike that open up and the woods
like again are dense but there's like a
properly like wide enough maybe to drive
a car maybe not a car but certainly we
went on uh one of those uh golf carts
side by side yeah golf cart for sure
like this trail goes through the dense
Woods in a one mile loop around the
whole property like that we met the
owner and he's like yeah dude I go
around that Loop twice every morning oh
that's great yeah yeah like the guy
built a house himself wow and he's like
super connected and and uh what year did
he build it
2017. oh so it's pretty new man that the
all the internet's loose are already on
it
on Zillow right now
yeah it's a beautiful house though it's
really awesome
yeah I mean I've I really hope to have a
career for for a good while to come so
that we can just keep building I think
that's the main thing stressing me out
is just like to to build and build like
I mean just what it cost to put this
ramp in the back of the house you know
because we had to build the deck and
then the it adds up quick it adds up
quick man when you have building going
on all the time like it's just money
flying out the door
and so yeah I'm building at my place too
and I'm just like they quote you on a
price and they're over and you're just
like and you can't do anything about it
right it's [__] you know it's
becoming an adult yeah there you go
yeah that's sort of a classic move with
like construction like I know people
work in construction and like you always
try to make a bid you know to get the
job but everyone's under bidding because
once you have it same with like selling
a movie like you give them like a low
budget and then once you're in you're
like ah
we're going over budget like yeah they
sort of at that point they're like oh
[__] we're already in this deep depends
on who you are for a lot of movie
directors you go over budget that's like
a black market record all right well at
least for the construction
all right hey well this if this comes
out Thursday we have UFC 292 coming out
do you have any predictions for that
dude check this out
um hold the card let's see who's on yeah
yeah I think you've been looking up a
lot of [__] today great job I mean dude
whether you got uh Sean O'Malley and
against uh Amanda Lemos for the co-main
um
and uh all right the main cards
like dude it's a great card it's a it's
it's a it's a great card I
apologia I saw all Joe in Tennessee
because the Lex and I chose uh to look
at properties in Nashville like strictly
because there was a big UFC event in
Nashville they had a fight night so
like I called up Dana White's office and
I was like hey you know
um and all Joe was there
and uh I'll just still gets a tough time
man I'll Jermaine Sterling the reason
why he gets a tough time is because he
became the bantamweight champion on an
illegal strike it was an illegal need so
the champion got disqualified the
champion was perion and some people
thought it's the first time ever
somebody became a champion without
winning they just took an illegal strike
and um that wouldn't have been
controversial but what happened was all
Joe says I don't even want this belt
because I didn't earn it you know and
everyone could have thought oh like
that's
you know there's a real Integrity in
that and then the next thing you know
it's like he's just like you know
holding up the belt everywhere and
supposing with pictures and there's
nothing wrong with that you know there's
nothing wrong with that but there were a
lot of people that looked at it and
thought oh he said one thing he did
another and then the more the people
were hating on that then he like leaned
into it and he just started trolling
with it and uh he kind of turned a lot
of people against him so now he's in
this position where like when they show
him on the screen at the event like a
lot of people are booing him
but dude at this point the guy has
defended the belt and he worked him dude
like I mean all Joe and and I heard
people give him some beers and I ran
over
I ran over at all jokes
like I ran over to all to all Jermaine
Sterling and I was like dude I respect
you man you know like I just don't I
don't want to hear him getting booed the
guy the guy who who gave him the illegal
need Pierre young like Audrey came back
and beat him legit defendant is about
against that guy so there you go like
leave him alone then he beat everybody
else in his spot he's defended over and
over and over again and he's a huge
favorite against Sean O'Malley oh really
yeah undefeated Sean's will tell you
Sean O'Malley will tell you but there
was one like contestable loss maybe two
his foot and then the last one was his
record is what like 16 17 and one he'll
tell you that he didn't lose to cheat
over but come on okay yeah how do you
think and I love Sean O'Malley I love
both these guys so I don't want either
one to lose but if you had to put Al
Jermaine's gonna beat him three to one
favorite so there you go I'll tell you
exactly who's gonna win this whole car
Marlon Barrel is going to win because
he's the bra black sheer is going to win
because his name's sick Ian Gary will
win 100 and Gary is gnarly zenway lay is
going to win
I'm a casual
and uh Al Jermaine Sterling's gonna win
even though I love all of them I feel
like we lose a lot of steam when we get
too deep into the fighting but I gotta
love it I love the fighting if you're
here's something interesting
um the the UFC Instagram page has like
28 or 37 million followers it's a huge
the webpage
whoa the Instagram page has like 37
million followers
uh uh yep 37.4 million so uh before the
last pay-per-view I see this Instagram
collab post
Bert Kreischer and the UFC whoa and and
uh it's Burt Chrysler does a funny
little bit he says to his wife he says
no I will not have sex with you because
it's UFC 291 tonight and Dustin porrie
is fighting he goes into the slide promo
for the thing so it's funny like Bert
Kreischer comedy mixed with UFC and like
it's just so genius I saw that and I was
like God Bert kreider's picking up
followers up to UFC's 30 million
follower page just absorbing followers
from from them and so when I was at the
fight at National and dude how cool is
this we watched the fights in in
Nashville and it was the same
I shouldn't even say this but it was the
same night as uh the Jake Paul versus
Nate Diaz and the UFC event ended before
the actual Jake Paul versus Nate Diaz
fight began and uh Dana White has he's
always got this killer private room in
the arena so we go on and it's like yeah
what's up Dana you know
hanging out in Dana White's private room
and lo and behold Dana's got a huge TV
and and now Nate Diaz and [__] Jake
Paul are walking out for their box so we
watched and sat down and watched the
fights with Dana we've sorry we watched
Jake Paul versus Nate Diaz yeah with
Dana White and watching fights with
Dana's so much fun what'd you think of
that fight the Paul and DSi I wasn't mad
at it I think that that the consensus is
completely right that
Nate Diaz
wins even when he loses for sure there's
nothing there's there's there's
absolutely nothing that about that that
tarnishes Nate Diaz's Legacy he got the
bag yeah and he did not 20 million
that's what he made that's amazing and
so it was a it was like a decision is it
confirmed that he got 20 million but I
think the next day I remember reading
that he didn't get knocked out though
right it was just a decision like in the
end yeah whatever I mean but you could
you could totally tell that he wasn't
really he didn't care he didn't care he
wasn't trying to care he uh did his he
kind of climbed him yeah he was trolling
him hard he made it fun to watch like uh
I mean look at who else Jake Paul fought
uh Ben askren not Ben astronaut cold
like that I love Ben askren but that's
uh and Tyson Woodley or Tyron Woodley
Ironwood knocked out cold like
I would say that Ben ashgren the way he
got knocked out by Jorge Moss at all
with that five second fastest UFC
knockout of all time was like really
like you know that that like that's
gonna be the the thing that Loom's ever
been asking is like yeah bought into
Jake Paul more so than than the the Jake
Paul knocking yeah what's your what's
your thoughts on Jake Paul uh trans
going to the UFC to fight
yeah to uh to fight Diaz
he's gonna get worked yeah will that
happen I don't know I mean the age
difference there I'll tell you one thing
that uh he's gonna get [__] Merc
daddy dude Wahlberg
in like a straight MMA fight yeah and an
MMA fight get I don't know man a
thousand persons I know I'm like the
least expert probably in here but no no
Jake Paul is a strong young guy who
trains a lot doesn't matter Paul
Brothers have wrestling backgrounds yes
don't forget that yes so it's not uh
it's not guaranteed what's gonna happen
um
um I'm not betting that there's going to
be an MMA fight for Jake Paul
but I know that he did a deal with the
pfl to make it possible so we'll see
what happens so was it hard for Dana to
watch Nate Diaz lose to Jake Paul
because Dana White hates Jake Paul I
think he always said like well if he
would fight one of these one of my
Fighters he would for sure lose like was
it was there any reaction from Dana
White I don't
I I you know I think he's interested you
know I think it's interesting I don't
think it's controversial that Dana White
watched that fight I think like big whip
yeah you know Chinese industry like he
would be paying attention to everything
like it's interesting he's watching
there's no [__] talking like uh from
Dana to Jake I I know I think it was
just like well me seeing like yeah well
it hears this kid is 26 he's fighting a
guy he's almost 40. he's like you know
like yeah I mean like nothing like
that's not just obvious and and uh yeah
you know normal there wasn't any like
real vitriol or anything like that he
wasn't like super invested in uh being
hateful it was just it was interesting
it was super interesting and and the
only reason I brought it up is because
Dana White's social media guy Eric was
right there as soon as I saw Eric I was
like dude I saw that Bert and UFC
collapse and I gotta get in on that and
so when you guys brought up UFC 290 two
we got all into the weeds talking about
fighting but what's important here is
that I have to Smash Bro Chrysler's
effort and I gotta make a UFC 292 promo
to collab oh okay UFC so they gave you
the green light yeah for sure oh sick
and Bert did it on 291 I'm doing it on
292. oh that's all right yeah three four
or five days oh it's got to go up
before Saturday right well yeah yeah
three days oh shoot Wednesday's tomorrow
oh damn
thank God we had this conversation I
gotta come up with a great idea quick
uh I have to smash Birds effort
all right yeah I mean you can get choked
out while announcing it and see how long
you can last done with the show guards
dude man that last one [__] your neck
up that last one messed my neck up and
then what I did yesterday well
apparently he did the choke out wrong
was with the consensus yes I saw Bisping
he was supposed to put it in the v and
he put it on the forearm according to I
saw uh to check this out I saw Michael
Bisping in Nashville at the the national
Fight Night
and uh
came out of the bathroom I was I was
like Yo dude like uh I don't agree with
everybody giving you they're not
everybody I don't agree with anybody
giving you grief he's like huh it was
like on Rogan Sarah Matt Sarah and Rogan
we're talking about you chug down he
hadn't heard about it at all oh I just
bummed him out
he hadn't heard about it at all and I
was like uh I didn't seem like he you
know like if somebody sometimes they'll
make it they'll say they didn't hear
about it
I can tell he legitimately had not heard
about it yeah wow that's funny and I was
like dude you did it great man those
guys you're like I don't care what Joe
Rogan says you're a nice guy
[Music]
yeah wow so did he say like oh yeah I
like did he say anything conversations
These Guys these guys run to go take a
leak and run back like it was a terrible
time to try to have a conversation
hilarious wow all right well you have a
heart out ah are you doing okay Steve's
got the heart out today huh I've got
I've got the heart out today and I'm
gonna go get couples massage with Lux
that's sweet that sounds like you could
use it yeah what are you supposed to do
for whiplash just massages and Ice baths
it's worse than Whiplash like the most
compromised part of my body is my neck
with this degenerative disc disease you
degenerate yeah like I'm beating up the
weakest part of my body and doing what
sucks with this dude everything about
that [__] sucks
um oh wow like do not do anything that
makes the pain worse yeah shut that
window dude I'm still skating
there's nothing stopping me riding my
new ramp let's go do a sign on a nice
bath dude see if you like it dude I got
what am I gonna do to promote 292. it's
uh all Jermaine Sterling and Sean
O'Malley
is the headliner I'm Bros with both guys
what if you make some kind of well like
you'll do something for the winner like
jumper Bros with both I want everyone to
win but whoever wins gets
like something it's got to be something
that performs well where is it from what
if you call up both of them and you're
just like dude I want you to [__] win
and then you call the other one and you
I want you to win you know because I
don't have Baja's number
it's in Boston yeah it's in Boston
um TD Gardens massive
it did I mean the UFC is massive dude 19
000 people ah but what was that thing
that I saw since we got so deep into
fighting uh the UFC changing the rules
yeah there's two two rule changes one
time for eye pokes I saw that
and it was like if you get a cut like or
if you get like a like a headbutt or
something like that you have an access
to a cut man in the middle of the round
huh
I love that both of those are designed
to keep fights happening like more time
for an eye pug what that means is that
they they have more time
um
to prevent a doctor from going in there
and calling off the fight yeah yeah look
at Fighters will have access to a cut
man after being cut by a foul or
accidental headbutt
all right I mean I don't know what a cut
man can really do he could probably like
like is it like on Rocky when he's like
cut me Mick and he like cuts his eye
which is the blood can come out so he
can see and it's not swollen brought to
you by Jeff Riley nice it's more about
like this is more about like a try to
stop the bleeding or like so like Nate
Diaz in the master doll they wouldn't
have stopped it because he's bleeding so
much
like if like that what's access to the
cut man doing I mean like when like when
the round ends and you go and you get
the cut man he like uses the big huge
Q-tip to put apply pressure and then he
puts the Vaseline to try to stop the
bleeding like yeah nice brick they're
like maybe somebody can explain in the
comments
[Laughter]
um I think that's great I just love I
love the UFC I love I love everything
about it and um yeah I was never really
into the UFC until I started hanging out
with you guys so I'm trying to learn
more and more I mean do you love
watching it dude I do I enjoy it I never
I used to watch it like when like
Anderson Silva and Chuck Liddell were
fighting but then I stopped for a long
time uh and then got back into it
recently yeah turned it back welcome
back welcome back yeah it's fun man I'm
I'm like even more casual than Scott
who's like the Casual of all casual I
remember I remember Wisconsin confident
casual you know like no I remember it's
constant funniest and and I did that one
and you cut me off I did that one on
purpose God's money is because he want
he watches all of the of the the MMA
YouTube channels he gets all the news
and he's got all the Time in the World
to listen to that like the jail son in
like you know but then when it comes to
the fights
he like won't even bother watching and
he'll Google the results after they
happen yeah or you know what I've been
doing lately is like
streamlined oh lately what I'll do is
like I'll I'll watch uh like a YouTube
of like some nobody just like commented
like oh it's left it's right and it's
like I'm like in the 50s listening to
the radio but I'm like listening to the
actual UFC fight live
she listens to the UFC fights on the
radio on the on YouTube they're
commentating they don't show it on the
screen oh you're watching the fight
companion no no I'm watching like actual
guys that are like okay it's left from
Diaz it's right from you know if they're
you'd prefer that yeah kinda because you
can play Call of Duty while you do it no
because it's like I don't know it's just
like I can't have the visual well I like
listening it's like imagination like in
the 40s and I'm sitting in my chair in
the living room listening to the Dodger
game are you like whittling as well like
why do you want to live in the fourth
place Solitaire yeah they just want to
live in the 40s he's in his 40s no no
like I'm in the fields like he's in the
40s listen to radio on the radio around
the radio I'm like listening like it's
like a Dodger game it's just I like it
better in my brain it's like an
imagination
okay
um what was uh you let the guy who
tattooed my head Mike Santa Fe you said
you can have my house
because you were going on a date yeah I
went on a date did you convert points on
the board I uh yeah we watched the
what radio program
yeah I thought my voice went lower but
maybe I'm just knowing my head yeah it
was a nice night we watched the uh there
was a meteor shower that was out
oh wow since it's
yeah so did you did you shower this
person
it was a pleasant evening
that's a lot to say about that all right
hey guys most
um I think that that uh the the title
for this one is the big news you know
like the big news about like uh
I don't know I mean well the big news
call your house
Vinnie
I'm actually getting married
like I've been engaged for
well over five years
and now I'm actually gonna get married
right we don't have a date but we got
the property and that's what we were
waiting for you got the property the big
announcement that you're still engaged
that you're still planning to get
married not that Paul got married
big news guys I'm still gonna plan to
get married sometime somewhere what we
know where now
yeah that's good that's huge
congratulations
it's a big step
okay yeah okay everybody I love you
thank you
how about that man a lot of UFC stuff
but [__] I love the UFC you know what I
love even more my new Ram yeah okay
yeah dude and as always man thank you
guys for sticking around to the very end
just for the people who can see on
YouTube look at the stained job
that's it for me baby
my back